now their Lord Faraj how does that sound
a peerage for the parties acting leader
Nigel Farage you kept of course could be
on the cards if one of the three
frontrunners in the leadership contest
wins it well I'm joined now by one of
those frontrunners Paul Natalie former
deputy leader of UK band leadership
candidates so what's this Lord Faraj of
the dog and duck good idea I would leave
I think it'd be a great idea mean you
Kip should have been given more peerages
all pages and E's actually since 2010 a
David Cameron obviously has a visceral
hatred of us and we were never award is
one I think maybe now with trees are may
in the seat we may well get peerages and
if we do get peerages their natural
farad should be the first on the list
because of the achievement small problem
a sink you've sent no no no it's
absolutely out of the question he said
it to me a couple of times on this
program
well if he's offered it we'll see what
he says internally within the party I
think it would be a fitting tribute to
the man who gave us breakfast either
now even though Nigel hasn't been in the
House of Commons he has probably been
the most influential British politician
since the said wouldn't it give that
meaning you want it to be you wouldn't
it be giving the next leader if you keep
a bit of a problem is you know as we all
know Nigel Frost has been a huge figure
in the political firmament for so many
years now dominates UK B's been leader
or acting leader four times now doesn't
he have to step back a bit if he's got a
platform in the House of Lords
overshadowing the leader if it's you I
don't think so I mean let's not forget
I've had a huge platform and you Kip as
well I mean I've been the party chairman
I've been the deputy lead that I've been
head of party you know and if we don't
bother to polish I mean you know who'd
finish first you all night obviously
across the country more people know
Nigel Farage but the two of us have been
the face of UK probably for the past
decade we were closely together and we
will continue to we're closely together
if I am elected as the leader yeah but
the continuity Nigel candidate is Rahim
kasam isn't easy
that's who Nigel's backing Nigel isn't
backing anyone in this election I don't
think it would be right that he did so
because as the party leader he shouldn't
be influencing how the party vote and
look you know my track record with Nigel
is there for everyone to see we came at
this together and the both of us sorted
out the last time you keep
in an existential crisis in 2008 and we
took us from zero percent of the polls
to finishing second in the European
election okay so there are many shades
within the leadership candidates now
about which direction and how much
emphasis say you kids should have on so
many important issues now want to put
some flesh on the bones of your policy
beliefs first of all we've got some
clips of you talking about there the
refugee crisis of course very very
important at the moment given what's
going on in there or the end of the
so-called jungle camp in calais and well
this is what you've said about to
refugees I want to see if you still
let's stick with it mr. Nuttall one of
the founding principles of the European
Union mr. timmermans is freedom of
movement of people what we're probably
allowing in now is freedom of movement
of jihad and I fear in the future in the
very near future we will all have blood
on our hands as a result so you think I
mean amongst that's freedom of movement
burden amongst the refugees there could
be those that want to do harm to the UK
do you know what happens a couple of
weeks after that speech Paris okay I was
absolutely right in what I said and the
other issue regarding the refugees is we
need to find out if they are actually
refugees or whether they're economic
migrants or jihadists or indeed jihadism
you Isis have made a perfectly clear
what their intention is and it is to
flood the European continent with jihad
ease and we've seen what happens in
Brussels we've we've seen what happens
in Paris and if we don't get a grip on
this then I do fear there will be more
attacks so so on the people let's refer
to the jungle camp all the people who've
come in and some of them as we know it's
questionable whether their children or
you know do you think we should be
letting any of them in and today we've
got the call from President Ollanta to
take well a thousand five hundred more
well I think we should be checking their
age and as I say you know I'm not sure
how we do that but I believe it is not
beyond the width of man's check the age
of these people and if they're not
children they shouldn't be coming in
because let's not forget these people
are breaking international law they're
breaking the Geneva Convention and
they're also breaking the Dublin
protocol which is part of you law
whereby you have to claim asylum in this
fair safe country in which you land
these people should be dispersed in
France NHS of course huge in British
politics comes
top or close to top in the surveys of so
many people's concerns now you believe
that there should be I don't know if you
still believe that there should be more
private involvement in it this is
another clip of you I believe is Moloch
hangover from days gone by and
unfortunately where we come of fortune
will be coming and all the population of
quite frankly I introduce well I mean we
just to explain to our viewers and cheer
I'm sure you're aware we we put the
bleep in their Knoxville bleeping out
what you're saying because the the
audience reaction there and now it's
some pretty fruity language it must be
said do you still believe more
free-market involvement in the NHS subs
or Hosting's in 2011 and a parliamentary
by-election in which I stood the
Hosting's was flooded with with hard
left activists look what I have said
about the NHS is simply this I believe
it needs to be streamlined it cannot be
right there fifty-one percent of people
who work in the NHS in England are not
clinically qualified it's too big it's
cumbersome and well I do believe we
could have more free markets is is in
places like procurement where by the NHS
itself is paying sometimes ten to thirty
times over the odds for drugs if you
brought in a private company they cook
you could hire and fire them on results
that they got for the buck the
streamlining interests interesting then
you then go along and following that
naturally if it's smaller it can deal
with fewer people that those that
thought it should get some kind of
insurance and then that's the way they
they take the burden off the anything
what I was talking about where I'm told
much streamlining isn't streamlining in
the sense of cost we should be spend
more money on the NHS and UKIP's
commitment and it's last manifesto was
three billion pounds a year what I want
to see is that money spent on doctors
and nurses not minute middle
management's and pen pushers now I'm
you've been deleting quite a lot of your
social media is that so well yes you
have well nothing at all I don't think
so no you look I know that no no
skeletons there I mean if it comes to
this this real scrutiny of what I've
been saying but IIIi don't believe I've
been deleting anything off my social
media maybe you've got the wrong
candidate
okay what about well what do you views
on abortion then I I believe that I
would reduce the the the number of weeks
probably down to 12 weeks I've been
pretty open about that but that isn't
going to be you kid policy when I come
to take on the leadership if I'm elected
you know what we were quite committed to
is holding national referendums if a
certain percentage of British people
sign a petition
it would trigger a referendum it's
called direct democracy I have my
opinions on abortion all the people
within the other or the people were in
the party have to have a referendum on
that I mean I think it's a personal
belief or would you have a referendum on
that in one of these direct direct
referenda you're talking well well that
would be for the British people to
decide we would open all of this kind of
thing or because we believe in direct
democracy we believe in referenda and we
believe in following the people and
you'd have one on capital punishment
well if enough people decided that that
was required then so be it look you know
I'm relaxed up about all of these kind
of songs until me I mean you're in favor
bringing back in tension and sometimes
you want to bring it up in terms of
capital punishments I've gone I've been
quite open that I believe in capital
punishments for the killers of children
people like Ian Huntley Ian Brady and
whatnot which is what the majority of
the British people think what about
climate change I mean what effect do you
believe me do you believe it's happening
and what effect you believe that
humankind is having on making it happen
I believe that the climate has always
changed and no one can deny that but
what I do question is the effect that
man is having on the climates I mean you
know why was the globe warmer a thousand
years ago than it is now why was the
globe warmer 2,000 years ago than it is
now you know I think there needs to be
far more research into this before we
make leaps into pushing policies like
the climate change Act for example which
harm our economy and lastly just Donald
Trump we know Nadja fraud is very keen
on seeing him elected if possible in the
United States you must be heartened
about the latest few Rory with Hillary
Clinton and there's emails and GE and do
you think that there was some of the
accuses about Donald Trump and what he's
been doing to alleged to be doing to
some of those women do you think some of
them are making it up I am quite open
that I
not a fan of other candidates in the
American election I would probably vote
for the Libertarian candidate Bennett's
boys talk I mean the locker locker room
talk about I would never advocate that
kind of language